what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the dark knights of steel
storyline now uh there's a couple ways
that we can handle this because this is
issue number six so it's technically the
end of volume one so either we can just
continue on doing these as they come out
adding them to the playlist and letting
you guys stay followed up there or we
can wait until all six issues are done
which barring no delays will take about
six months and then go forward from
there uh so let me know which one you
guys are interested in and i'll also
check the uh the audience retention
analytics to see what people think as
well right so having said that as you
guys know with the dark knights of steel
this is basically an elseworld story in
dc comics right just an alternate
reality story that's really really
amazing now what we end up doing here
and this is really really cool again
this is where roles are shifting
characters aren't who we traditionally
expect them to be uh is that we pick up
with zala jorel now as you guys know
that's not who supergirl traditionally
is that normally supergirl is kara zoro
and so the fact that she's related to
the jorelles is a pretty big deal
because what you have is this
conversation where she basically comes
home now the last we saw her there were
a few things going on one she had
basically attacked the the kingdom of
storms right so basically jefferson
pierce uh black lightning as some of you
guys know him and between the death of
his son and the death of him that's
basically led the house of storms or the
pierce's family to war against the elves
the other part of this and really
seemingly the reason why uh why
supergirl is here is to basically pay
respects to the leader of the house of
elves we end up finding out of course
following his death that she's basically
his daughter so in essence superman and
supergirl are brother and sister as
opposed to being cousins so this is a
really really it's a cool change to be
honest with you guys and in truth the
more i think about this the more i'm
like that kind of seems normal right but
the crazy thing about this is that what
goes on is basically supergirl says that
what she had been doing while she was
out there is she had been hunting for
the green man now as we know the green
man is basically lex luthor joker slash
green lantern kind of combined together
into a singular villain so there's a lot
of questions about what's going on
because the funny thing about this is we
end up switching over to harley quinn
now one of the hallmarks of harley
quinn's character in really in more
recent years has been her relationship
with poison ivy and it kind of made
sense right like like literally when you
had gotham city sirens and all that kind
of stuff that having like team ups and
different events that happened where
you'd have harley quinn and poison ivy
working together or whatever the case
was it always just worked well right
they were kind of like the one-two punch
of like female villains and things like
that in dc comics so when dc was just
kind of like you know what in four penny
in four pound and then put them together
as a romantic couple it just worked and
it was really really cool to see i
always thought it was fascinating and so
that's why tom taylor continues this on
because it has been for a while a very
popular aspect of the characters of
harley quinn and poison ivy and so of
course when harley shows up here she's
really sent as more of an emissary and
of course says like essentially the
queen of the house of elves needs your
help now of course the response of
poison ivy you would expect is i
recognize no queen but i'll do whatever
it is that you want uh harley quinn
but it's one of those things where we're
kind of given a bit of how discussions
have unfolded on the back end when she
basically says look i'm not going to use
my use my force right to strictly
protect the house of l because the queen
asks for it but if you ask for it i will
give it to you the only thing that i ask
in return is that you live here with me
and when harley quinn's response is like
this again like in the the response of
poison ivy is like this always the
romantic thing is kind of there now one
of the things that tom taylor sort of
toys with and doesn't necessarily give
us a definitive answer here is of course
back during that point in time having
like relationships between people of the
same sex was very much frowned upon and
so assuming that concept from the real
world carries over into this comic it's
something that that harley quinn
wouldn't readily make aware to people
that are out there only individuals who
are of the highest order can do that and
basically get away with it largely
because any kind of attack on those
people would lose the will of the people
themselves or the favor of the people
themselves of like the greater governed
society harley quinn's a court jester
you kill her nobody's gonna care
and so it's just one of those things
where like they they largely seem to
have kept their relationship secret but
in the end the response of of poison ivy
is i will basically build an army for
you and i will use my force in order to
keep you safe now the question that we
would ask here is what good could the
forest of poison ivy possibly do against
a veritable army that's super powered
because it's different when you have
like soldiers with like swords and
shields that are making their way
through there but tom taylor answers
this question immediately and the best
person he chooses to do this with is
wonder woman because literally she's
flying overhead on her pegasus with the
intention of arriving at the house of
elves and of course as soon as that
happens poison ivy basically uses her
force to snatch wonder woman down bring
her down to the surface and then
immediately like incapacitate her now
well it doesn't really happen
immediately it's one of those things
it's kind of funny like wonder woman's
just like stand aside and and the
response of poison ivy is like no so
literally wonder woman like kicks a tree
in half picks it up and goes to attack
poison ivy with and poison ivy's like my
trees right so like literally things are
popping off right things are getting
kind of nuts but like poison ivy
basically uses vines and ensnares wonder
woman quite readily and so that's when
you kind of get just how capable poison
ivy is and it's good to see it continues
on because the truth about this is that
if you're not overly familiar with dc
comics poison ivy is somebody that you
sleep on right you don't really realize
just how capable she is and just how
deadly she is one she's an elemental so
she belongs in the same vein of power
somebody like swamp thing right being
able to control the elements of the
earth or really the the greenery of the
earth so trees and and bushes and stuff
like that but it's one of those things
where you get this kind of funny moment
because she literally tells wonder woman
one woman's like you know like i'm not
here for violence but understand i could
destroy you if i wanted to the response
of poison ivy is amazing here right
she's like and i can command fungus to
rot in your brain and thorns to seed in
your eyeballs i can make your life like
i can make the inning of your life
incredibly painful i can stretch this
out two weeks but it's just it's nuts
it's one of those really really cool
things that's why i say poison ivy is
incredibly capable and so in the end the
response of wonder woman is basically
that she is really here because she has
more faith in supergirl than than
hippolyta does that hippolyta of course
is taking the reports given to her about
the about the attack on the house of
storms and is like yep that sounds like
something the elves would do to war and
then like that's basically it right
that's really all it is whereas wonder
woman's like no like i know supergirl
we're romantically involved there's a
little more to her than this so i have a
hard time just arbitrarily accepting yep
this sounds like something the elves
would do and then just being willing to
go to war against them with the house of
storms and so in the end of course
supergirl basically shows up and and
wonder woman is like let's go have a
conversation and so that's when you get
this really really cool thing because
ultimately you end up having this
statement by wonder woman who's like
like as far as our reports are given to
us from from the the kingdom of storms
which again they don't necessarily know
that jefferson pierce is dead yet
they're like you know the king says that
you killed his son and she's like what
in the world are you even talking about
and that's where things get murky
because we seemingly saw her do it and
so the question is if she's like okay
what like i have no idea what you're
talking about here i didn't attack the
king's son i didn't i i have no clue
what you're what you're referring to
either one she's a great liar two she
didn't actually do it or three she did
do it and doesn't remember it so like
there's a few possibilities about what's
going on but in the end of course kind
of pulling on their romantic
relationship right their closeness there
albeit a little more stoic than you
would traditionally see with like harley
quinn and poison ivy where it's far more
gushy far more emotional different
things like that that is kind of like
okay we can't like we literally have to
hold these kingdoms together right like
we have to find some way to keep this
war from happening like it's literally
the two of them who are like we're the
only ones that really stand between
essentially a giant world war between
the house of elves and the kingdom of
amazonia and the kingdom of storms and
so what we end up doing here is
basically switching over to basically
batman presenting to superman a piece of
a fallen star right basically a little
meteorite shard that crashed into earth
of course as we know it's kryptonite
it's the piece of kryptonite that we had
seen uh previously and it's actually
what led to alfred revealing to batman
his true identity when batman started to
succumb to the effects of kryptonite
that he's the result of an affair
between jorel and martha wayne right and
it's just one of those super well kept
secrets and that's one of the reasons
why uh joerl was always so friendly
towards bruce and would always say
things like you're as much a part of
this family as anybody else and so
that's where bruce wayne actually
reveals the truth here to superman right
he's like look you know alfred was able
to to make some lead and or at least use
some lead to basically encase this
kryptonite hence the reason why it's not
really poisoning you and why it's not
really affecting me but in the end i am
like i'm i'm your brother right i'm the
son of your father and it's really
really interesting because what this
does is it creates a kind of closeness
between the two of them that wasn't
necessarily there before or at least
you'd think it would because literally
superman grabs the grabs a piece of
kryptonite strips off the metal and then
plunges it into the chest of bruce wayne
flies him into the sky and is like this
is out like this world is ours to rule
there can be no challengers and throws
him down into the ground and then leaves
and it's just like damn son superman's a
dick like this is so cool like as soon
as that happened i was like wow okay so
i guess superman's a villain now this is
where things get really really crazy
because at that point you switch over to
like this carriage with this older
couple and i know you guys already know
what's happening but it's a carriage
with this older couple that end up
basically real writing to where it is
that this thing just fell right and
they're kind of like i mean i don't know
exactly what it is but like something
fell over here when they get there of
course they find batman with a piece of
kryptonite in his chest and then they in
turn take the kryptonite out and so when
it's kind of like i mean what do we do
like what do we do here the response is
like we take him to the palace and
that's when he wakes up and he's like no
do not take me to the palace do not take
me back there and so ultimately the guy
who is identified as jonathan of course
the other one being martha so jonathan
and martha kent that what they end up
doing is basically bringing batman
taking batman under their wing back to
the kent farm at this point we switch
over to uh to basically the kingdom of
storms right to john constantine now
remember constantine is kind of the
catalyst behind all of this that there
was a prophecy that basically foretold
the arrival of the jorals the fact that
the jorals would ultimately end up
conquering the world it would lead to
the destruction about the kingdoms of
storms and how to you know amazonia and
all that kind of stuff but as soon as
once people realized just how capable
the jorals were and as they essentially
took over started ruling the kingdom and
so on and so forth following the the
death of the of the wanes and whatnot
what this did is it it really kind of
created uh just an inherent ceasefire
because nobody knew for sure if the
jorels were going to end up living up to
the prophecy but as things have started
to unfold the words of the prophecy are
seemingly ringing true and so that's why
constantine's position is really more
important now than it's ever been before
the other thing about this is of course
you basically pick up with uh with one
of these guys showing up here right one
of the the teenagers showing up here
who's actually revealed to be tim drake
right him arriving here and speaking
with uh with john constantine that
constantine of course is struggling with
the death of like the king by the death
of jefferson pierce and so on and so
forth and in a lot of ways kind of sees
himself as the fault of this because he
was the one who was supposed to protect
the king and so on but what he also
reveals here is he knows that tim drake
is one of batman's robins that in
reality here the robins of batman are
basically spies or at least tim drake is
that he was sent here in order to keep
an eye on the kingdom and report back to
batman and that john constantine figured
that out incredibly fast and that's why
tim drake was assigned to constantine so
constantine could occasionally feed him
false information and basically create a
circumstance where batman didn't know
what was true or false and so it would
very much muddy the waters that it's a
much better idea than giving batman
straight lies because then ultimately he
could figure it out and say okay so the
truth is most likely the opposite of
what tim drake is telling me but by
muddying the waters and merging emerging
truth with fiction it makes it very
difficult to discern which one is which
and so ultimately john constantine
switches his tune and is like all bets
are off i'm done playing this game so we
literally cast tim drake out right it
throws tim drake out of the room and
into the hallway where tim drake ends up
meeting princess jennifer now remember
princess jennifer is one of the
daughters of jefferson pierce she's not
the oldest so so technically the the
oldest daughter of jefferson pierce is
actually having her coronation at the
moment or at least they're preparing for
it and so she's going to be the one that
basically takes control of the throne of
the kingdom of storms but as soon as tim
drake is thrown out in front of jennifer
jennifer's like what in the world is
going on and the response of constantine
is he's one of batman's robins and
that's all it takes because remember
batman is part of the house or the the
kingdom of elves and because batman is
associated with the kingdom of elves and
so is supergirl and supergirl is
seemingly the one who killed both
jefferson pierce and his oldest son the
rightful heir to the throne the response
of jennifer is like everybody from the
kingdom of elves are our mortal enemies
if we see them we kill them and that's
exactly what she does with tim drake she
doesn't actually kill him although it'd
be crazy if she did right she just
starts like electrocuting the hell out
of him going straight up like emperor
palpatine like timothy drake's all like
tim drake saw like luke skywalker
begging like john you know john
constantine to save his life and
constantine goes all darth vader and
it's like no you know stop killing this
kid you know we can't go to the the
coronation of your sister with blood on
your hands and so ultimately tim drake
is just banished right she actually she
gives him a reprieve right literally
it's just like you're banished from this
place do not come back if we see you we
will kill you but do know that when you
arrive back in the kingdom of elves tell
them war is coming that it is inevitable
and it is unstoppable and that there's
nothing they can do to prevent our wrath
so as soon as tim drake shows up there
right he literally just starts talking
to the the kingdom of elves and is just
like i need to speak with batman but of
course he's basically told like batman's
missing and alfred and the other robins
are out hunting for him so you get to
talk to us and so the statement he makes
here is okay i'm here to tell you that
war with the kingdom of storms is coming
jefferson pierce has been killed and the
king of the kingdom of storms was killed
by zala jorel everybody's just kind of
like what are you even talking about and
so he literally just starts like just
dishing the information right he says i
can tell you there was an attack at sea
everyone i've spoken to on the ship had
the same thing to say and it's not as
though it was just a general questioning
he's like i i gained i gained trust
right like i bribed i threatened and the
story was the exact same every single
time that if there was any inconsistency
right if what i was being told was a
false story somebody somewhere would
have cracked but no one did which means
either they all have the most incredible
fortitude of anybody ever or they're all
telling the truth and that if they all
saw zala jorel kill the the king right
if they all saw zala jorel basically
attacked the king on that boat right and
the king's statements that zelda rail
had basically killed his uh killed his
son if any of this was a lie then
somebody would have revealed it
therefore it can't be which means it
seems true zalajjorel killed the king
and so the funny thing is that his
allegiances are a little a little
questionable here perhaps because tim
drake spent so much time among the among
the kingdom of storms but he's like
they're simply acting to protect their
pain of their family their people and
their entire world they're living up to
a prophecy and the truth about this is
they're acting in response to what they
believe zala jorel did now the immediate
response to that is it doesn't matter
right it's obviously a lie they made up
zelda or whale would never do that make
sure you maintain your allegiances right
keep in mind who it is that you serve
here and so it's one of these things
where it's like there is a mystery here
there is truth in there somewhere but no
one seems interested in finding it and
no one's stopping to ask the question is
there anything else really going on here
so a wild little moment here is a
conversation with the queen you have
general waller remember amanda waller is
the leader of the forces of the house or
the kingdom of elf and that when amanda
waller is talking to the queen what
amanda waller does is provide this very
insightful statement here the queen says
i'd like to consider this alone general
waller and the response of of waller is
i understand your majesty but i just
simply wanted to say that diana was
right the amazons will follow their
queen into battle against us right that
has always been that way that the
kingdom of amazonia has always been an
ally of the kingdom of storms and that's
just how it is literally they need no
other reason than that and they will not
take any other reason than that they've
always been allies they will always stay
allies and they will both go to war
against us she says so i will simply
leave you with this thought i do not
believe the love between diana and zala
can be broken if hippolyta dies diana
becomes the queen of the amazons and
because diana loves supergirl so much
that will be our life our allegiance
right that'll be our forge it'll be the
way in which we bring the amazons to our
side and so it's a really really
interesting thing because it's like
supergirl can be the one to convince her
now the thing about this is that's a big
gamble right we don't know
we have no idea how that would play out
it could very well be that the house of
elves could organize the assassination
of hippolyta and when diana finds out
she would literally look at supergirl
and be like you're just like all of them
and then war continues not only that not
only does war continue that war would
actually be worse because now the
amazons siding with the kingdom of
storms isn't even based on just some old
standing alliance now it's a personal
vendetta right so it's just like damn
any possibility of bringing them to
their side is totally gone and so that's
where things get really really crazy
because at that point you switch over to
superman who ends up having this kind of
momentary conversation with uh with
jimmy olsen right kind of the the guy
who keeps an eye out for everything and
he's like is there any sign of batman
he's like no we don't we haven't seen
him or anything like that he's like okay
then i got to take off because i'm going
to try to try to find some way to stop
all of this and so what you end up doing
is you switch over to john constantine
basically creating a kind of diagram and
of course he ends up summoning etrigan
and that's the nuts thing because he's
like i don't want to talk to you etrigan
i want to talk to to your host right now
keep in mind historically speaking in in
dc comics etrigan was always part of
like the demonic side of things right so
like even when you when you focused on
anything not your traditional superhero
uh basically vertigo type stuff so you
had like etrigan swamp thing to a degree
john constantine zatanna right all that
stuff right all those magical beings
that exist out there that etrogen was
always a really really cool concept but
one of the things i want you guys to
notice is unlike the main dc universe
etrigan's not rhyming that r the etrigan
always rhymes whenever he talks it's one
of the things that's really entertaining
but can occasionally be annoying
and so when he when etrigan ends up
switching back over to his human form he
says gone gone oh etrigan rise again the
form of man which normally it's gone
gone the form of man arise the demon
etrigon right and then just kind of
switching back when it comes to his
normal host which is jason blood the
reason why i say his normal host is
because the current host of etrigan is
actually raziel cool which is an amazing
concept we don't know how that happened
we simply just know that it did but what
raz al ghul is really was really
summoned here for by uh john constantine
is that what constantine is looking for
is for rozal ghoul to use the powers of
the etrigon demon to actually resurrect
both jefferson pierce and his son
because the hope of doing this is that
if it happens war will be averted of
course ultimately he says that's not
something that i can necessarily do you
know his his response is like the heart
of jefferson pierce is gone right
there's there's no way for me to bring
his heart back there's no way for me to
basically resurrect him because i can't
create a heart out of nowhere and and
like put it in his body he's like
however when it comes to his son jacob
that i can do like that i can resurrect
him the problem is he won't necessarily
be the person that you remember him
being if i bring him back he could be
completely evil it could be completely
terrible now what this seems to indicate
here is that what was algo would do is
take them to the lazarus pits that in in
taking them there they would they
basically end up returning to life and
then come back now that's the caveat
because where he says he may not
necessarily be the same person that you
recall when it comes to the lazarus pits
you're usually taken there and then you
experience a momentary bout of insanity
when you come back you lose your mind
temporarily now you usually end up
reverting back to your normal self but
that may not be the case here that what
may be the case is that the price you
pay for basically being resurrected
through the lazarus pits is you
permanently go insane and so who knows
what jacob would end up being like if he
was brought back but the the price that
uh that raz al ghul asked for is
basically the price of the titans right
the teen titans or maybe it's just the
the titans in general like they're older
i'm not entirely sure that what
constantine's been doing is actually
keeping them hidden now we don't know
exactly why it is that raz al ghul wants
the titans it's seemingly just that he
does and so we don't necessarily know if
a bargain is actually struck between the
two we actually switch over to superman
arriving at the kingdom of amazonia now
as soon as he shows up there he's
attacked by all the amazons because no
man quote unquote is allowed to set foot
on amazon itself on amazon property now
of course it's kind of a funny thing
because as they all start to attack with
swords and all that kind of stuff they
all break on superman right and
literally he's just fitting them all off
seemingly with the greatest of ease and
he's like i don't want to fight any of
you and that's when hippolyta shows up
and she's like for a person who doesn't
really want to fight you know you are
doing a lot of fighting and she's like
that's because your people attacked me
and she's like well no no man is allowed
to set foot on a you know set foot on
amazonia and he was like i'm not
actually standing on it and so then like
lois lane chimes up you know chimes up
with this kind of funny moment where
she's like a technicality is really not
in the spirit of the rule
right like it doesn't mean literally
stepping foot on amazonia it means just
don't come here right that's basically
what the rule means
and so she's like okay you know
hippolyta is like okay like you're
looking for me calo then you found me
and she just stabs him through the
stomach with her sword now of course he
doesn't die as you would expect or at
least as you might think he does i mean
i i didn't expect him to die but the big
question you have to ask here is how was
she able to stab him with a sword that
was not made of kryptonite the answer to
this which is really really cool is when
lois lane shows up here and lois lane
basically starts speaking with him now
historically speaking lois lane and
superman were the one-two punch of
romantic couples and comics they were
the original
they were the original power couple and
no other power couple will ever be on
par on the same level as like superman
and lois lane right i mean it's just the
way it is in comics they stand above all
else and so it's one of those things
where tom taylor kind of toys with this
idea of there potentially being like a
superman lois lane type power couple
here but of course we don't necessarily
get that instead a lot of it's general
discussion and a lot of it's really
heard just saying you were sad because
you know queen hippolyta has a magical
sword so obviously you're weak to magic
and that's kind of the answer that we
get which makes sense right superman
does have an inherent weakness to magic
it's not just tom taylor pulling it out
of his ass and then just kind of rolling
with it but one of the things that lois
lane says here is she's like look
there's got to be something bigger going
on and superman's just kind of like i
mean it seems like there is but it
really seems like there is now lest we
forget remember his attack on batman so
what it looks like is superman's playing
everybody for a fool right he's
literally like he literally has every
intention to conquer the world and he's
just kind of pitting everybody maybe
against themselves but he's essentially
duping everyone and so lois really shows
her hand here and it's just kind of like
i mean we've been giving information to
queen hippolyta we've been telling her
what's going on but she's hell bent on
this idea that it really was supergirl
who killed uh the son of jefferson
pierce and seemingly killed jefferson
pierce as well but the thing about this
is it feels like something else is going
on here that there's some kind of
invisible strings that are that are
pulling at everything right there's
something bigger happening and i can't
quite figure out what it is and the
response to superman is i feel the exact
same way take me to queen hippolyta we
can prevent this war from happening and
that's when lois lane says no you can't
it's not possible for you to stop this
war from happening queen hippolyta and
the amazons they're already sailing for
the lands of elf the war is about to
begin with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end i love this
story so far it's so good because it's
so unique i absolutely love it but thank
you all for watching don't forget to put
your opinion down on the question at the
beginning of the video and i will catch
you all later
peace